the children brain development program
has been around for I guess 15 years and
it started by asking the simple question
of why is there a negative relationship
between SES socioeconomic status and
almost everything you measure to do with
health literacy etc so I think the child
brain development program is in a
critical period of its development and
so we've gone through this very
foundational work that was perhaps of
childhood we've established some core
principles around how early adversity
gets under the skin gene environment
interplay how development works and now
we're at this exciting new time in a
redirect rich environment full of new
tools to study child development new
ideas and need discipline joining us I'm
on the verge of some some interesting
discoveries and the other thing that our
group is moving into as we turn the
corner is the adolescent period and
whether adolescence is another sensitive
stage so it's not just what
psychologists coming together a group of
pediatricians coming together we have
fly geneticists we have people who work
in machine learning we have
anthropologists coming into the room
bringing each bringing their own
perspective and their own science it's
the ideas that draws everyone and the
opportunity to work together to on the
most challenging questions that that we
have I think it's affected the way
education in terms of full-day
kindergarten that how that changed in
Ontario for instance and all over the
world is because of this kind of
research they're constantly going to be
questions around science of child
development and see far has played an
instrumental role over the last 15 years
and supporting that science and looking
to the future look like a wonderful
place to continue to generate that
science to continue to develop
leadership and and and lead in this area
[Music]